of all the people involved in the horror
of Grenville tower there is one group at
the center of it all from whom we have
not yet heard the firefighters who were
actually in the building at the height
of the inferno one of them is Damien
McGee a London fireman for 20 years this
weekend is off to another firefighters
wedding with colleagues who were also in
Grenville tower he spoken exclusively to
Sky News about the horrors that
confronted it in the small hours of
Wednesday morning when we got there we
were coming over the Westway he could
see it miles in the distance and we were
hoping and praying that it was a
building site that it was a new build on
the construction that was going up
because it just how could it possibly be
we just couldn't believe what we were
saying no one on the truck everybody was
just in shock and we were miles and
miles away we realize what we've got
what we were heading into once they were
inside the tower the human cost became
clear I had no idea how many people who
got out by the stage how many people
were trapped well I can't tell you was
the screaming children screaming and
other residents in the block particular
I remember one kid's voice that I could
was sticking out higher-pitched and all
the other voices screaming screaming for
help and that's and I they probably had
some sort of hope when they say in all
the fire okay down there like you would
do for us to get in and help them you
know precedented temperatures employing
acrid smoke the crews battled to
exhaustion what I seen was when they
were coming downstairs they were nearly
on fire they were in bits or completely
exhausted and they were done in you mean
the temperatures are killing them and in
a lot of cases these crews work on
themselves without any firefighting
media now anyone who's seen the
television shows I've seen that that
whole building was completely engulfed
in flames we were all inside that
building and a lot of times the crews
that the ones that were there initially
in the crews ahead of me were upstairs
going into floors without any water
simply just looking around and just
tried trying to do their best banging on
doors and kicking in doors and trying to
get people out even those that
firefighters did manage to rescue
brought with them stomach-churning News
a little boy we'd a little boy who came
downstairs with him with his mother who
was in a very bad way and he seemed sort
of okay and very very shocked and car
lovely little fella probably got five
years old and we asked we need to know
what flat were you were in one time a
flat why you win is anyone else in that
flat because what's in it goes in there
and he's thrown I thought he said my
brother but he's dead his five year old
boy knew that his brother was dead yeah
he said yeah we asked was any Westerner
flies any when the family is anyone else
in the flats and he said just my brother
but he's dead now you're a 20-year serve
professional fire officer when a little
boy tells you that it breaks your heart
a little bit
it's very sad look I just you feel
useless and helpless we're there I know
that they looking at us to save them
everybody is you know we're hearing now
we'll save you but I mean it's not
saying it's unfair and others but I mean
we were put in a situation where we mean
people need to know where we can't you
know meanwhile that is I've got a high
the fire crews needed the help of police
to get in and out of the building as it
burned on I'd like to say a big massive
thank you to Metropolitan Police who did
an actually amazing job protecting us
from that pill thing that was falling
down on our heads and all around us and
so many of them were hit time and again
were massive lumps of debris and metal
and the composites and look to me like
concrete was falling off the top of the
building which it probably was and that
was bombing down all around as so many
people get smashed the piece of that
nevertheless running back and forwards
backwards and through that with
casualties and with people without their
selfless efforts many of those who did
survive would not have done so but for
some of the firefighters in the tower
there is a feeling of failure all the
firefighters that were there were gonna
be killing ourselves wishing that we
could have done more because of the
amount of people that we've lost and not
only that because we see some of them
but we watched families die well I mean
yeah I was I watched people die and I do
anything if I could go back I would
probably think well I'll do this but it
out of a difference you know I break the
rules more than what I would have done I
would have dropped a certain I would
have ran up there and I'd have done this
and that but yeah there's a few things
that I yeah that I wish that I would
probably donor could have done more but
essentially I mean that was a tyrant
many of the fire crews at the scene as
the blaze tore through the building
still do not feel comfortable speaking
about it what they saw will stay with
them for the rest of their lives
Debbie Bowden Sky News